la dixième semaine de grève martin
desjardins est ce qu'on a le droit de
refuser cette proposition cette main
tendue est intacte morale que vous avez
sans doute
exactement c'est qu'on a pris en fait
une entente sa garde invité toutes les
associations nationales à venir
s'asseoir à une même table et on
continue de l'exigé d'ailleurs ça fait
qu'il tour 24 heures que je l'exigent
sur toutes les tribunes qu'on veut que
la classe soient présentes ont
représenté ensemble 300 mille étudiants
donc c'est près du plus de la moitié
beaucoup plus de la moitié des étudiants
en grève actuellement et donc c'est
important qu'on soit tous assis à la
même table et nous avons continué plaidé
en ce sens là mais évidemment puisque la
porte qui est ouverte de l'année ça fait
des mois qu'on le demande donc de voir
hier qu'une ouverture on va la prendre
on a déjà annoncé qu on l à cette table
mais évidemment pour nous d'abord il
faut s'entendre sur les prémices de
cette table de discussion là et déjà
s'assurer que tout le monde est
représenté c'est une première je veux
bien contente oui allez vous y ait les
mêmes cela transmet pas mais
présentement il est même pas de date de
finale il n'y a pas de lieu prison que
de besoin qu'on embauche en vous appelez
bonjour martine ça va bien aujourd'hui
on se rend compte mercredi midi mercredi
matin première exigence est ce que la
classe y est la classe de leur dire non
aldi non là vous êtes quoi on continue
plaidé pour que la classe dont vous
allez pas les réunions tant qu'elle
n'est pas justement annonce est en recul
mais membres n'ont pas donné de mandat
autre que d'inviter d'exiger que la
classe soit là je vais continuer de
plaider en ce sens là et pour nous c'est
important c'est essentiel que la classe
représente un certain donc je comprends
bien on exige que la classe au présent
la nuit est davantage parce que tout le
monde y soit parce qu'il y aura pas deux
il se confie l'un d'eux se réglera post
élections mais american lépi on peut
dans ce cas de l'api du public les gens
se disent dix semaines de grève est-ce
que possible dérapage idéologique
ils font tout ça pour 1625 $ bien on
revient par la case départ pour les gens
qui disent la ministre de négocier les
ballons on veut que tout le monde soit à
la table mais je pense que c'est
légitime pour fait que tout le monde
soit là ta mort se bat depuis comme vous
le dites six semaines de grève c'est
1625 mais c'est 75 % d'augmentation la
facture totale ça va s'élever près de
1800 dollars donc oui c'est légitime ce
canton est de faire et on est rendu
justement la phase où il faut s'asseoir
pour discuter et je pense que c'est là
qu'ils aient rendu moment crucial de
s'assurer que tout le monde et
veauchette on a fait des propositions de
parer d'or donc c'est important qu'on
puisse les mettre son temps